[Applause]
he was always going to show up to claim
these new territories which are not his
to declare to his people that Russia
will be victorious in what he's pitched
as an existential battle for the
motherland harass
[Applause]
and of course these crowds cheered him
off that's what they were here for
[Applause]
the fight in Ukraine has not been going
that well for Vladimir Putin and his
call for partial mobilization has shown
significant cracks in the edifice of
Russian patriotism he needs this moment
he needs to try and tell his people that
their fight is worth it
the day had all the Pomp and ceremony of
a formal process treaties signed solemn
Talk of the right to self-determination
in the U.N Charter but make no mistake
there is no legal basis to what Russia
has done
I want the key of authorities and their
real Masters in the west to hear me so
that everyone will remember it people
living in lahansk Donetsk Curson and
zaporiza have become our citizens
forever
that's not how Ukraine sees it or the
West which immediately slapped fresh
sanctions on Putin's regime but his
invective tirade against the West is
contagious patriotic Russians draped in
their flag proclaiming a kind of
reworked Soviet Union filled with a cold
war style Fury
defeaters we are one nation for sure
Russians belarusians ukrainians shuvash
ordovians all of them are Russians
against you we will defeat you you will
never win not on your life
this is the protection of our national
interests the fight for our state's
existence its prosperity and greatness
and in red square they cheered their
commander-in-chief a man who keeps
raising the stakes in an Ever more
dangerous conflict
Diana McNeese Sky News Moscow